hi guys it's over at again and somebody
requested me to do a MOBA steel jungle
tutorial and I figured there are so many
tutorials on YouTube on how to make
supports using mobi steel jungle but not
actually explain explaining the set
itself so today I'm not going to explain
how to make supports or buildings or use
mobi steel jungle I'm going to explain
how the set works so if you're new to it
that you can kind of understand it a bit
more so first of all we've got the basic
pieces we've got the vertical pieces now
there are three categories of vertical
pieces and three versions of each one
first I'm just going to take the normal
one this is the one that you're gonna
want to use most of the time we've got
the bar vertical 1h as you can see this
is a very low piece can be used to can
be stacked to create more bigger parts
but I wouldn't recommend using this
small piece just for well well sometimes
you just need to use a small piece and
then there's the bar it's called H 4
which is basically just four times this
small piece and if you're wondering
where all that H number thing is about
this follows the same system that I see
t3 has with the H system whereas one H
is one is raising the terrain with well
one level so this is h1 as you can see
it's just as high as that piece of mobi
steel jungle and if I raise it three H's
it's going to be just as high as the h4
so that's the way that works and then
you could see that there was also the
bar it's called extended and that thing
is very very long and it's perfect for
supports on I'm going to show it so
we've got the bar vertical one H that's
this one we've got the bar it's called
h4 but then you've also got the extended
one and as you can see this one is very
long you can pretty much raise this a
lot I'm not even gonna count how many
ages of this is but as you can see it's
very high now this is great for support
of coasters since you don't want to keep
sins if you don't care about the support
just going on forever and you want to
create a very high support it's better
you just use a vertical extended one
instead of stacking these h4s because
that's going to take quite a while now
there are also the centerpiece and this
is what I'm talking about you've got
three different placements of pieces
we've got the well the normal one which
has no name but it's sometimes referred
to as the corner piece so if you've got
sets for example and they say it's a
corner then it will conform to this
placement but there's also the center
piece which is over here and that is in
between two diagonal normal pieces as
you can see so normal pieces on these
lines and in the middle of a tile and
the center pieces in the corners of the
tile
don't ask me why they call this a corner
piece and this is Center it because it's
not really in the center that is because
this set uses a quarter tile placement
as you can see so if you think of a
squatter tile placement like this then
that's in the center so that's that and
then there's also the edge piece and
this is works the same way except it's
between two corner pieces on a
horizontal line so as you can see it's
like the center piece but then on the
line so if I take another one of these
corner pieces you can see that the
center piece is in the well in between
two normal ones in the diagonal line and
the edge piece is in between normal to
normal ones in a straight line and one
thing to know about the edge piece is
the fact that it behaves in kind of
strange way because of its placement as
you can see I can now place it only on
these lines and not actually on the
other lines but if you rotate it you'll
be able to place it on these lines but
not actually on these lines so let's do
something to keep in mind you can only
use it on X or Y at the same time
because of its strange placement okay so
that's the vertical things then we've
got their horizontal things they are
just the normal things we've got a
normal horizontal bar and a quarter bar
I would recommend in any case just use
this normal one except if you just want
to use a quarter bar somewhere to
connect a Coast coaster track to
supports for example and any other case
the horns the
is the best way to go if you want to
create large horizontal line same goes
for the diagonal ones works in the same
way except you've got a quarter piece
and a normal piece okay then now we've
also got these slant bars and this again
works in the same way as the vertical
ones a one H will go up one H as you can
see two H is gonna be twice as steep
we've got the three H piece which I mean
the three H piece and the for H piece
these these are pretty much the the low
slanted boys and also as you can see the
one H and the 2h have vertical ending
and the three H have has a horizontal
ending and the same goes for there for
the for H and then 8h in the 12 H so
that's something to keep in mind and as
you can see this H 4 also has an H
placement which works the same way as
the vertical edge placement as you can
see this is just to connect it to an
edge support because if you didn't have
that little piece you could never
connect an h4 to a edge vertical support
and also as you can see the H 4 also has
that same extended thing whereas it's
just one big thing so that's also very
handy for supports and yeah same goes
for these H 8 which is twice as tall as
the H 4 also has an H piece and an
extended piece which is very useful for
supports and then there's the really
steep one which is whereas it is also an
H 12 yeah nuts over here for some reason
which is really steep and this is really
something for very high supports same
for this piece got an edge placement and
an extended placement and then we've got
the diagonals which work in the same way
so it's no really and it's not really a
need to explain that but I would like to
tell you to keep one thing in mind these
things are slightly less steep than the
straight ones and I can show that and
explain you why that is because as you
can see there's
diagonal one seems to be a bit less
steep than the horizontal one because
obviously this one needs to cover a
greater distance and well basically goes
up to the same height now something to
keep in mind with this is that because
of this straight horizontal a ch3 will
kind of look just as steep as a diagonal
h4 even though this one goes up a little
bit more it kind of looks just as steep
from the side so that's something to
keep in mind if you use diagonal
supports I always like to make them just
a little bit more steeper than the
straight ones because then it looks like
that just as steep okay now we've got
some weird odds and ends in this set for
example we've got the caps and these
caps are very useful to connect to a
track also I'm very notable about these
caps is their placements I'm going to
show that often in a moment as you can
see they've got some weird placements so
for example the horizontal cap has an
edge placements like this so as you can
see the only way to connect it to that
is using an edge support and similar to
that the diagonal one has a center
placement so if you've got for example a
corner support and you want to connect
that to a cap the best way to do that is
using these horizontal quarters because
using those you're able to connect them
to a corner piece so that's the way to
do that now with these vertical caps
it's basically the same story for got a
normal one which is supposed to be used
for a corner piece and for what Center
one and an edge one so that kind of
works in a similar way however there are
also offset pieces for all of these and
these are slightly lower pieces now I
found that to be most useful when you're
building a coaster and the coaster is
kind of low and you want to connect it
without going through the track
sometimes this offset piece works as a
connector but it might also be useful in
other things I know it's up to you to do
that
okay so then we've got the flanges and
there are many different pieces first of
all we've got the diagonal piece now
this goes on a corner placement on
either in the middle of the tile or on
the line
and then we've also got the centerpiece
which works the same way as the vertical
centerpiece it goes over there we've got
the horizontal piece with a normal
placement and an H placements and then
we've got the vertical flanges which
have the same placement as the vertical
poles a vertical one an H one and a
center one and then we've got the
slanted flanges for the four-h filling
the 8h supports and the 12 H finally
though to be to be fair if you really
want to be lazy and most people probably
won't notice you can also use a vertical
piece for the 12 H it doesn't make too
much of a difference I'm a perfectionist
and I've got OCD so I would I always
like to use the 12 H piece for that but
if you're lazy and you're already
supporting loads of vertical beams you
can always you can always do that to
save a little bit of time now as you
might notice there are no 3 H 2h and 1 H
flanges so you're gonna have to come up
with a solution for that
well thankfully I've got that for a 1 H
and horizontal works to age is kind of a
hard thing but horizontal just kind of
works is the only piece you can use for
it and then for 3 H and slanted flange
for comes closest to that so I always
like to do that so that's the way that
works you might also want to try using a
4h for a 2h becomes it because it's
slightly tilted but I'd like to use a
vertical one more than that because as
you can see the transition is for now
you've also got the flange angle which
is a diagonal piece so you must always
remember that slant is horizontal and
angle is diagonal as you can see
so for diagnosed aport like these you
just have to use the angled ones and the
same rules apply as for the slanted ones
works in exactly the same way only its
diagonal now something that often
happens when you're building with Mobe
steel jungle as you get this is little
not so smooth transition from one piece
to another so for that there are the
knuckle pieces we've got the regular
knuckle which fits on the regular
supports we've got the centre in our
core for the center supports and the
edge in our core for the edge support
and whatever you want to build and then
if you've got for example in inverted
thing like this there is even an
inverted knuckle for a casing like that
and if you combine an inverted knuckle
and a normal knuckle you can create a
little ball like that and it's nothing
too special but sometimes it might be
used for fruits for some things for
example the end of a support if you want
to have the ending of a support to be
smooth like this and there you can
always make a little ball like that's
and then and whatever kind of horizontal
beam you want to add to it and that also
works okay so those are all the pieces
in mobi steel jungle one I'm not going
to cover might be steel jungle too it
works in exactly the same way except the
knuckle is already a ball like this and
the supports are slightly thicker I
prefer no limit I prefer Mobe steel
jungle one but some people some people
prefer Mobe steel jungle to and it might
be useful some slightly thicker poles so
you might use that for buildings or
bigger coasters stuff like that and one
last thing because something that often
like confuses people is the fact that
you cannot hook up these horizontal ones
to the center piece and this is indeed
impossible there is no way you can do
this and the same goes for the diagonal
piece in the edge piece simply because
these offsets placements just don't
really work so yeah there's nothing you
can do about that so I'm sorry there is
however a movie steel jungle add-on
which is huge you might get lost in that
set but if you really want all the
flexibility you can get there is an
add-on with all the other pieces it's
got h5 h6
h7 all that kind of stuff you get more
placement center pieces that are
straight stuff like that
but it will put eight more sets in or
maybe even more yeah maybe like 13 or 14
more sets in your custom scenery folder
it's an entirely huge sets you might get
lost in it but then again it's very
flexible but yeah this was the tutorial
for a mobi steel jungle I hope you
enjoyed and learned something and thanks
for watching